good afternoon i'm captain dory corn
with the las vegas metropolitan police
department i'm here to brief you about
an incident that we're currently working
that happened at 2000 faster show drive
at approximately 12 53 today we received
a call for service
regarding an individual who had entered
a hotel property with a large suitcase
and a large duffel bag
he had dropped those items off in front
of the concierge area
and then he began to yell that there was
a bomb in the building and that people
better get out
at that time the individual then walked
out left the part of the area in a taxi
[Music]
and then about 15 minutes later the
hotel received two telephone bomb
threats
we immediately responded as we always do
these types of incidents we secured the
area and we began our investigation and
cooperation and in collaboration with
las vegas city fire department and the
clark county fire department as well as
our other partners to include the
security partners at all the facilities
here nearby
as of now
our initial investigation
indicates that there's no hazardous
materials
in the uh suspicious items however we
are in the process of double checking
like we do on all these types of
incidents we want to make sure we don't
miss anything so we're just going
through our routine process of making
sure that there's nothing else that we
need to address
but as of now this is an isolated
incident the area is secure and we just
can let the public know that the um the
immediate area if you want to avoid it
for traffic reasons we highly suggest
that fashion show drive las vegas
boulevard and sammy davis junior back
here are going to be blocked off as we
continue our investigation
with that i have time for just a couple
questions and i get to get back to the
investigation any information on the
suspect uh yes so we do our team did an
incredible job i think this community
can be very proud of our police officers
within a very very short time frame they
were able to track down locate and
apprehend the suspect that's involved in
this so he's currently in custody i
can't give you the particulars on who he
is or the details because it just
happened a little while ago
i'm sorry i don't have that information
at this time
you know our security partners do a
really good job keeping order and
maintaining safety within their
properties they made the decision to
secure the immediate area and evacuate
at least a portion of the property as
far as i understand the entire property
as a whole was not evacuated but a
portion of it was for safety reasons
our protocol for responding to this is
to say no matter where it's at we
address a variety of different uh
factors but ultimately uh we responded
as if it was any other bomb threat
particularly with the details that an
individual was involved it wasn't just a
telephone bomb threat as we initially
got it but with that folks i apologize
to cut it short but i will give you an
update or at least we'll send something
out through our public information
office to confirm everything that i said
and to confirm that it is safe